it's great to welcome back to the
program Chris Martenson who's an
economic researcher and futurist
specializing in energy and resource
depletion he's the co-founder of Peak
prosperity dot-com he first joined us
back in the valley free radio days in
the basement of a old Grammar School in
Florence Massachusetts most recently
with us in 2016
Chris thanks so much for talking to me
again David is so good to be back with
you and all your listeners of course so
let's start with the economy today
what do you sort of see what are you
paying attention to maybe in terms of
the Trump economic policy he talks about
trade deals a lot he has announced
tariffs on some goods from different
countries including China steel aluminum
what are sort of like the guideposts
you're following now in terms of
economic policy in the trump era well
you know a president can only affect so
much in any given cycle so you mentioned
a few of the things he's you know taxes
trade those are some things they can
influence but otherwise you kind of
inherit this large thing we call the
economy and right now we're at the
second longest expansion air quotes
around that word in history and so I
think what everybody who's is following
the economy is looking for is you know
when's the next downturn and in that
story it we're probably a little bit
closer to the end than the beginning of
this expansion and so what we're trying
to do is figure out what we're really
are we in this story and this economic
expansion is the weakest set you know
second longest but also the weakest on
record and so this is really a tale of
two worlds David you know we've had the
very very wealthy doing very well
largely because of nothing presidents do
but because of this body called the
Federal Reserve they print money shovel
it into the markets drives the markets
up and the people who own those assets
tada
get wealthier so that's been that's been
the story what they've been waiting for
is for the tail to wag the dog if they
you know Ben Bernanke first said it if
they could just drive interest rates I'm
sorry um interest rates really down the
bottom and that would spur borrowing and
if they could drive asset prices
sky-high then
that would rescue the economy it really
hasn't happened that way and we detect
that in all kinds of Statistics like
median income and how many families have
a thousand dollars to their name things
like that those statistics haven't
really recovered yet so you ask what I'm
tracking I'm just trying to figure out
where is the end because we know we know
there's gonna be a recession at some
point so the question now is can you
spot it you mentioned debt and this I
just realized it jogged my memory that I
wanted to talk to you about that in our
last interview you talked about the
concern you had over global debt and in
the last six to 12 months more more than
just less six to twelve months but
particularly in the last six to 12
months we've been following modern
monetary theory and we've interviewed
people like Pavlina Chernova and
stephanie kelton who worked with the
Bernie Sanders campaign and there's the
school of economic thought that debt in
and of itself is not really the problem
printing money in and of itself is not
per se a problem the question is what is
being done with the money that a
government prints and if the right
things are being done with it
it doesn't trigger these inflationary
spirals where are you on mmt I take a
completely different view I fall much
closer to the Austrian side which which
has a much more what I call a reality
based approach not that mmt isn't
reality based but but here's the reality
money is just a claim debts a claim on
future money money's a claim on stuff
the $20 in my or your pocket does
nothing unless we can take it and buy
coffee with it or a shirt at the
Salvation Army or something right so we
always have to look at what's the
relationship between the amount of
claims and the actual economy itself so
when you say economy we're talking goods
and services right things things being
made produced and sold with a value add
or services being delivered again
hopefully with a value add when we track
it that way we look at the increase in
overall indebtedness and the amount of
money creation that's happened and we've
never been in a period of history like
this and my view is that what we've done
is we've put extraordinary amounts of
promises and claims on the future and
the question is can those be paid back I
depart very sharply from the MMT people
who think
hey you know we haven't seen a lot of
problems with it so far therefore we can
conclude there aren't really any
problems with it and that's actually not
true historically speaking and I think
it's only temporarily been true because
all the world's major central banks have
been playing the same parlor game
thereby in our debt we're buying theirs
they've been stuffing it on balance
sheets pretending it doesn't matter but
it has to matter at some point otherwise
oh okay looking let's see if we can like
take that in pieces a little bit I don't
know that I've heard anyone on the MMT
side say that the debt doesn't matter
but I think just as a sort of thought
experiment the idea that not every
dollar of debt is created equal does
make a lot of sense in the sense that if
the Federal Reserve prints a hundred
million dollars and gives it to very
rich people who don't need the money
they mostly just save it and that is a
very very low economic multiplier right
it's not very economically stimulative
if you print a hundred million dollars
and you put it into I don't know funding
government health care that directly
creates jobs because there will be more
people now who are seeking health care
services that means that people are
earning wages and the government is
collecting income tax on some of those
wages so right away we see that just
printing a hundred million dollars and
adding a hundred million to the debt
depending on what you do with it has a
very different net effect on the economy
like that part you you would agree with
I would guess you take some exception to
that because what you just described
with spending it on purely consumptive
services right so it's wonderful that we
take a hundred million dollars spend it
on health care but what really happens
in terms of that impact the answer is
zero unless you do that again next year
so part of the thing that we've gotten
ourselves locked into at the government
level is all of this printing and
deficit spending to be stimulative but
unless you're spending it on increasing
productivity or you're increasing
spending on infrastructure which has
this long-term economic gain you're
really just spending it and and that be
the healthcare example wasn't a good one
but I mean certainly it sounds like
you're saying if I had said
infrastructure then there would be a
difference than rich people putting it
in bank accounts yeah you know with the
big asterisks which says they've spent
that money wisely right and so the
infrastructure is
paving another eight lane highway to
nowhere because we love cars so much and
maybe you said we're gonna follow
China's model and we're gonna connect
you know in cities by high-speed rail I
have trained Envy everytime I go to
China huge train envy but but you know
if we were spending it on some stuff so
it gets very complex very quickly but
the bottom line David is this if you
print money out of thin air you do not
actually create wealth doing that what
you do is you've created real purchasing
power but where did it come from and the
answer is it comes from everybody so
it's really saying that what we want to
do is is harvest a little bit from from
every person with savings out there and
then decide where we're gonna use it and
if we had a robust conversation around
that you could you could draw me into
that or a convinced we have robust
conversations on 2,700 page spending
bills in Congress right now okay so
point point without going fully into mm
tea exclusively you you do not agree
generally speaking with the MMT
theorists that at this point at least
oh you can't print your way to
prosperity absolutely not
let's talk about tariffs a little bit I
read a very interesting article recently
that sort of described trade wars as a
version of the prisoner's dilemma game
theory experiment but not the the first
one that's usually taught in game theory
101 but the repeating prisoner's dilemma
one in which actors tend to have will
have the information of the other
players before deciding what to do the
next time is that a good analogy how do
you assess the idea of the Trump tariffs
well you know I've long been this is
actually something that oddly I find
myself in the side of Trump with because
I've been saying this for many years
well before Trump came along which is
that you can't have free trade unless
it's truly free we don't have free trade
in the sense that I'm a u.s. business
person I have to comply with a whole
stack of laws because my country said
hey we want people to not be
discriminated against have you know have
disabled access to everything we want
you know workers comp health care
there's all this stuff I don't disagree
with any of it but if I'm and if I'm a
steel manufacturer I'm not but if I was
and I was in direct competition with a
China or in India which has none of
those protections who we said oh we're
only going to come
on price whatever you can ship it to
here that's really that's not free trade
it's not fair trade it's it's actually
something that benefits the
corporation's tremendously because they
get to go to the lowest cost environment
either in terms of lack of environmental
controls or cheaper labor or whatever it
is and then bring the product back and
say that it has you know the locally
produced product has to compete
that's not fair so if we say if we want
to say we don't want to have fair or
free trade fine but I think that the
idea here is Trump is the first
candidate that came forward and said I'm
going to speak to them to the persons
whose jobs have been exported I'm not
sure he's gonna get all the way there
but literally nobody else in either the
Republicans or the Democratic Party was
speaking for that vast swath of middle
America who's seen their job and job
opportunities mostly exported the good
jobs left but that wasn't an accident
that was an active act of policy that
was lobbied for and really granted by
both parties wasn't it totally missing
from the discussion that lots of the
jobs that supposedly would be
reinvigorated either through tariffs or
better trade deals simply don't exist
anymore because they've been replaced by
machines well a lot of them have in in
them you know that's really a trend
that's going to continue I I served on a
panel to help NASA was a hundred years
old now and they're saying what are we
gonna do for the next hundred years so
they had this blue sky meeting and asked
the question of really diverse group of
people what's the next hundred years
look like and the people who are there
from artificial intelligence and
robotics said there's not a single job
they can imagine that can't be done
better by AI and robots than humans
except maybe getting a massage but
they're they meant everything accounting
lawyer doctor you name it every
specialty is possibly can be done faster
better cheaper by technology at this
point when it comes to for example the
China relationship with the tariffs I
found it very interesting that even
though the Trump administration proposed
a list of some hundred plus items from
China that would have a tariffs placed
on them that that represented a
relatively small portion of the exports
from the United
to the United States
but the small list of counter tariffs
from China represented about half of
American exports to China what's the
long-term impact of that inequality or
imbalance well I mean what we're really
you know you have to scale it so the
United States imports a ton from China
relatively speaking China imports a lot
less that's why we have a huge trade
imbalance with China right so for them
that what they were doing was just
matching US dollar for dollar they said
oh you're gonna put a hundred billion on
fine we'll put a hundred billion on and
so that tit for tat on a dollar basis
means that on a percentage basis China's
putting a lot larger ding on there and
they did it you know it I think in a
politically smart way not unlike when a
local school board says we didn't get
our 4% raised well we're gonna cut all
the most valuable programs you know to
parents to really make the pain come in
China targeted us soybeans and things
like that so by hitting the agricultural
products they were hitting Trump right
in the political breadbasket and and I
think you know they're clearly saying
you can't push us around
and I realize this goes back away if
you've ever been to China you know they
value face and diplomacy and really
making you know being treated like an
equal and they deserve to be you know
they've got the first quantum satellite
circling the the earth right now they're
they're here they're not up-and-coming
they've arrived and still the United
States is saying you know things like
we're gonna you know put our gunboat
diplomacy around the islands and the
South China Sea you have to do what we
say and we're just gonna call the shots
and China's clearly saying not so fast
we're here too
my concern is that I'm not sure we have
the diplomatic chops in place right now
to to really pull this off maybe China
yeah very pragmatic
good good good understatement if I've
heard one but we may lack the diplomatic
chops right now to pull that off Chris
Martenson we will pause the conversation
there and pick it up with him tomorrow
we're continuing our conversation with
Chris Martenson he's an economic
researcher and futurist specializing in
energy and resource depletion he's the
co-founder of Peak prosperity dot-com
Chris I get asked often what are the
economic indicators that one can look at
to evaluate how an economy is doing and
of course there's really no one
indicator but what I'd be interested in
talking with you about is where
particular indicators are useful and
sort of what the limits of those
indicators are so let's start with one
that is often touted by presidents
either as accurate when the number is
good and about themselves or as fake and
or inaccurate if it's bad about
themselves or good for somebody else and
I'm talking about the unemployment rate
which Donald Trump recently bragged
about being three point nine nine
percent what can we deduce about an
economy from that number the
unemployment rate and what is sort of
outside of that well it's funny you
mentioned Trump because he was he was
touting the other side of that number
when he was running of course and now
he's you know it's saying oh it's much
worse than advertised and now he's
buying it wholesale because it seems to
support his his position here the
unemployment number unfortunately is one
of the most heavily how do I put this
diplomatically unreliable numbers that
exists out there right now and this has
been true every administration since
Lyndon Johnson when they first started
this series every president has put
political pressure to make that number
sing the way they wanted to sing and so
you would think it should be this simple
right how many people are capable of
working and how many are working that
should be the number but it's not it
excludes people who haven't looked for a
little while and it excludes people that
you know just sort of get dropped off
the rolls it double counts people who
have two part-time jobs is two jobs and
so all of that so really the number
itself is is not as useful if it was
just a simple measure of how many people
are capable of working and how many are
the actual unemployment rate is close to
twenty percent right now if you said how
many people want jobs but don't have
them you know that's the so-called the
the people who are no not in labor force
but probably would be if they had an
opportunity
we're probably closer to like a ten or
eleven percent unemployment rate right
now and of course as you know it's being
touted at three point nine percent so
big gaps in those numbers and it really
depends how do you account and so
there's a lot of I think legitimate
criticism about how that counting is
done so it's not a number I put a lot of
stock on I know the markets love it you
know first Friday of the month when it
comes out I don't like it that much
because
it's it's really got some pieces in
there there are they just don't add up
right now so that gets us to labor
participation rate during the Obama era
you had Trump many times talking about
we have 42 percent unemployment if you
base it on how many people are not in
the labor force and of course that one
to me is very deceptive because you can
have people that are outside of the
labor force because there's a problem
with the economy but if the economy is
really good and you have for example
two-parent households where one parent
chooses not to work because the other
parent is doing so well economically
that's an economic that's a reason why
someone would leave the labor force as a
result of the economy being good if you
have a lot of people retiring that's
going to push down the labor
participation rate so I have found the
labor participation rate conspiracy
theories is what I call them from the
right during the Obama era to be
incredibly misleading my right or am I
missing something
well it's it's reasonably correct to
look at the labor participation rate I
think because it's really not the one
the one income household went the way of
the dodo bird
it really I mean it was true during my
parents era I think it was partly true
during my early adulthood I don't think
it's it's not that easy anymore so a
simple example right now in San
Francisco the the median income that a
household can have is about is the
median incomes about seventy-five
thousand but to own a house in that city
you'd have to have at least two hundred
thousand dollars of income and so you
know how many jobs out there are really
paying people 75 or more thousand
dollars not a lot really honestly so you
know we're what we look at the
participation rate you have to
understand what kind of jobs are
available and and really how many of
these are part-time it gets it gets
murky quickly but again I think if you
want to see the number that really sort
of begins to tell the tale it's the ones
that I trust which is very easy to get
this data how what's the average savings
of the median household right how many
people how many households can access a
thousand dollars in an emergency the
answer is far less than half that tells
you I think really the true state of the
economy because you know David if you
went down you said tell me about the
inflation rate or tell me about this
true state of job
all of that all that stuff's really
murky I love to just cut right back to
it and say if people were really earning
as much as they needed to be earning
we'd see things like solid savings rates
and solid savings in the bank things
like that that we're just not seeing for
a wide variety of reasons but one of
them is real incomes have not kept the
pace with stated rates of inflation so
that was going to be the next area I
wanted to discuss right if we look at
inflation adjusted wages and is that a
value to look at over time over time but
again there's so much that's wrong with
the way we count inflation that that's a
whole topic all by itself but you know
it's just it's a statistical game and
the government is very very incentivized
to make the inflation rate as low as
possible why because there's things like
cost-of-living adjustments that really
bust the budget if we were stating the
true rate of inflation plus it it they
don't like it to sound like they're
mismanaging the economy when you have
extraordinary deficit spending that's
inflationary and so they love to be able
to say look we're spending a trillion a
year but inflation isn't that high and
that's actually not true one simple
example the the Bureau of Labor
Statistics counts health care as four
point eight percent of your basket of
goods that you buy but it's 18 percent
of the economy well where's the missing
14 percent well it's just missing from
their statistics why is that well
inflation in medical care is going up
hugely and they don't want to count that
so how do you how do you minimize that
you just say it's less of a person's you
know basket than otherwise would be the
case just an example that's called
weighting they do three big things to
mislead us on inflation and substitution
hedonic sand weighting those are the big
three and anytime you dig into them you
find Wow you can't really justify or
rationalize this stuff and the bottom
line is very corrosive because the
government's telling you inflation is 2%
or less and you're experiencing
something a lot higher than that
particularly if you're an urban consumer
which by the way seventy percent of
Americans are and all of a sudden you
find that that you can't begin to trust
your government in this regard is this
why it's so politically easy to paint
picture of the economy either a local
state or national economy federal
economy as being good or bad because
even if we agreed on a set of indicators
how we ultimately are coming up with the
data and what significance the data has
is not necessarily subjective as the
word I would apply but of unclear value
I mean is this is this why it becomes
such a political game to talk about how
the economy is doing yes and David these
these statistics all all of them that
were talking about they've been in
operation for 50 or 60 years and they've
been slowly eroded or corroded across
every administration this isn't a
partisan discussion everybody who's in
power wants things to look a little
better you know if possible can we spin
it this way or that way let's take this
way so it's really not an indictment of
any one particular party I'm just
telling you that these statistics the
more you dig into them the less you can
really trust them so then you have to
back up and say well what can I trust
you know and and here I think you know
the places I really trust what I'm
seeing is things like the opioid
epidemic that's not a sign of people who
are feeling economically vigorous or you
know participating in the wealth of a
nation when you look at things like the
levels of homelessness or you look at
maybe the state of funding of pensions
you know these are all examples that say
there's not enough surplus to go around
and that's really the conversation we
not ought to be having in this country
because it's a tale of two worlds the
economic pie is no longer expanding it's
kind of stuck debt as it has a habit of
keeping that that way but the elite are
pulling out more and more and more so
that just leaves less economic oxygen
for everybody else voila homelessness
lack of savings the opioid epidemic all
of these things are now fit with that
narrative and if you try and make sense
of how things are doing from what you
read in the paper when you compare them
against statistics it's hard but I'm
telling you the trouble isn't what
you're reading the troubles in the
statistics that starts to get into when
you talk about a pie that's not
expanding that starts to get into a
little bit of the conversation we had
back in August of 2016 about the idea
that so much of our economy
loans debt investing in stocks it's all
based on the idea that there's going to
be growth forever indefinitely and of
course as you and I discussed last time
at some point I mean of course we can go
to other planets I guess but the planet
does have some fixed level of carrying
capacity and resources and ultimately it
seems like we're kind of getting back to
that conversation again that the entire
economy is based on the idea of
indefinite growth forever bingo now this
is the heart of the conversation and and
this is the most of course this is my
work in the world it's really do it Peak
prosperity every day is get out there
with this message not terribly popular
still with this idea that we can't grow
forever it seems like an easy
conversation to have but it's not
because it it runs into every possible
belief system we have not least of which
is our financial markets require
infinite exponential growth perpetual
growth bond markets you know real estate
markets all of that stuff so we've been
told over and over again we need this
growth we have to have no conversation
necessary it's just gonna happen but if
you wander with me now over to this
other part of the story where I track as
well what's happening in the environment
insects have disappeared like crazy you
know the right whales aren't breeding
this year on and on and on there's just
like this whole litany of things that
says Wow though we're at carrying
capacity the earth is really beginning
to adjust in serious ways there might be
no ice in the Arctic before you know it
the krill are disappearing phytoplankton
that's just all these warning signs and
you know we're not going to other
planets
spoiler alert you know if anybody wants
to go to Mars there's a Great Valley in
Antarctica you can go with the same
temperature in zero water and try it out
for a couple weeks it'll be awesome
come back in two weeks tell me how
awesome it's going to be and maybe with
Aki Mars but this is the most forgiving
spaceship we've got if if we can't
operate or thrust me we can't operate
Mars you know a very unforgiving place
so here we are and that's what that's
the conversation we really need to be
having which is at some point you know
grade school math you got to stop
growing so we either do it on our terms
or we're gonna end up doing it on some
other terms again up euphemism Chris
Martenson check out his website peek
sperrit e.com Chris always great to talk
to you
thank you David my pleasure